you are about to see the second of three
films which have been made to help us
size up our enemy Japan to beat the
Japanese and to do the job thoroughly we
have got to understand them thoroughly
the Japanese is not easy to know I've
lived among them for 10 years and I can
testify that they are as different from
ourselves as any people on this planet
the real difference is in their minds
you cannot measure Japanese sense of
logic by any Western yardstick their
weapons are modern they're thinking 2000
years out-of-date to the 70 million
people of Japan Hirohito their Emperor
is a God who direct descent from the
great Sun Goddess Amaterasu they believe
that he personally owns Japan its land
its resources and even themselves and
they believe that it is the right and
destiny of Japan's Emperor's to rule the
whole world to bring about the
fulfillment of this destiny and to
destroy all nations and peoples which
stand in the way of its fulfillment is
the sacred duty of Japan's army and navy
the army of Japan is a well-trained
sternly disciplined force of fanatics
deal to reckless courage by a primitive
moral code which assures to every man
who dies in battle and immortal life
among the Shinto gods
behind the fighting forces stand all the
wealth and power and resources above
people whose national dream is to see
Tokyo established as the capital of the
world from Tokyo the Japanese have for
over 11 years been carrying on one long
uninterrupted war again and again
Western economists have predicted that
Japan's economy must soon collapse but
Japan is stronger today than ever before
in its history an adaptable people the
Japanese have made good use of the
inventions and conveniences of the
Western world which might fit in with
the plan for world conquest which is
their national obsession
non-essential industries in Japan have
it all but wiped out but the Empire has
recognized but one need the need for the
materials of war efforts to hold down
prices have failed and inflation has
decreased the purchasing power of the
end
Japan's gold supply is carefully hoarded
no longer forms a basis for her money
but Tokyo's bankers see their turn
coming later when Japan begins
exploiting the lands it has conquered
most eagerly sought securities on the
Tokyo Stock Exchange are the shares of
government control corporations set up
to develop the gold and iron and timber
of the Philippines the abundant rubber
and kena Belaya the oil and kaneen of
the Dutch East Indies all the raw
materials needed to make Japan
self-sufficient in a war which many of
its leaders believed may last a century
never an inventive or creative people
the Japanese have always depended on the
scientific and industrial knowledge of
the Western world
and now that they are at war with
Britain and the United States they find
their chief source from which to borrow
fast changing production techniques in
Nazi Germany
in the theatres of Japan Nazi methods of
propaganda are also copied to good
effect the Nazi concept of total war is
highly satisfying to the Japanese mind
for throughout its modern history Japan
has been a totalitarian state preparing
for total war playing their closely
supervised part in total war our japan's
metropolitan newspapers which ate the
great american dailies
or a stick of type can be set it must be
approved by the army the Navy the police
and the Foreign Office no story or
editorial no picture or cartoon may be
printed which opposes the concept of a
Japanese ruled world
thus to the Japanese reading public the
progress of their holy war is an
unbroken succession of triumphs
every disaster becomes a victory and all
news is good news
for every channel of public information
is being used to impress upon Japan's
people that the war is proceeding
according to a divinely guided plan and
that the people's part is merely to
double and redouble their sacrifices on
behalf of the Emperor and of their sons
and fathers away at the front
greatest single source of Japan's
fighting men is its peasant population
long use to hard work and self-denial
toiling from before dawn to long after
sunset the farm family accepts hard work
and squalor with the unfeeling stoicism
of a disciplined race homes are crudely
built with a framework of wooden beams
and walls of muds and chopped straw in
these huts
Japan's peasants have for generations
raised sons to fight for their Emperor
there are few luxury crops in Japan
today practically everything has been
replaced by crops which give the
greatest nourishment all grain and rice
belong to the state the whole crop is
bought by the government at a price just
high enough to keep the peasant alive
and working
and in a nation where land is the chief
source of food and life no square foot
of farmland
however meager is left until
to protect its supply of hardwood Japan
has four years practice reforestation on
a national scale and today it's lumber
like everything else it produces is
going into the war effort in one way or
another
to make sure that on the farm not an
hour is spent in idleness no material is
wasted every rural community produces
useful handicrafts
in the towns and villages home industry
is also the rule and in these homes lies
much of Japan's industrial strength with
each home a miniature factory the
nation's total production is almost
beyond estimate with the same fanatic
zeal that inspires the soldiers who may
so devotedly support the Japanese people
are today working for the destruction of
the land they fear and hate most of all
the United States the land which more
than any other the Japanese have caused
to remember with gratitude and affection
when in 1923 Japan was wrecked and
broken by an earthquake it was the
United States which was first and most
generous in giving aid into Tokyo and
scores of other shattered and suffering
cities for millions of American dollars
shiploads of American supplies to save
lives to heal the injured and to help
rebuild Japan
today Japan's restored cities are filled
with mills and factories turning out
materials warm in these factories there
is no shortage of labor farms and
villages comes an endless supply of
girls eager to contribute to the war
effort for a year or two before they
marry and begin bearing sons for the
Army and Navy willing to work 14 hours a
day for little more than room and board
a fine factory meals of boiled rice fish
and teeth better fare than they had at
home since nearly a decade before Pearl
Harbor
Japan's heavy industry has been
mobilized on a war footing its materials
machine tools and workmen integrated
into a long-range program to build up
and maintain the Japanese war machine
to make up for shortages of strategic
materials it accumulates great
stockpiles of raw materials by importing
them from China India the Netherlands
East Indies and from Western nations
Japan's state religion is Shintoism
which teaches that Japan is a heavenly
land protected by their gods who have
even taken the form of a divine wind
which scattered and confounded enemy
fleets Shinto gods exist in rocks trees
and rivers and even the souls of men who
have died for their Emperor are
worshipped as minor gods
and in the immemorial fashion of these
ancestors they fortify with pageantry
and savage symbolism belief that
innumerable and deities in them to be
the CRA's of the world early in life
japanese school children learn to feel
the proper reverence for national heroes
for by implanting such devotion the
Empire is assured to be youth imbued
with fanatical courage and militarist
ideals
from infancy Japanese children find
their days strictly scheduled till the
discipline of total war physical culture
groups they harden their bodies learn
the obedience to orders which will make
them good warriors in later life
by wreaking pitiless destruction upon
unarmed cities and their helpless people
and by slaughtering all those who stand
in Japan's way the young Japanese will
win honor and grace in the sight of his
gods for they have decreed that it is
Japan's destiny to achieve mastery over
the whole world to bring to all peoples
the blessings of the samurai code
learning to read and write the complex
Japanese language of more than 4,000
characters there is stern discipline for
the mind
never they allowed to forget at the way
of Japan is the way of the warrior and
at modern weapons of war are as glorious
as the samurai swords with which their
ancestors won honor and immortality to
the Japanese child
these are not mere planes and ships but
symbols of the conquering bite of his
August Emperor
as he grows older the future Japanese
soda devotes a large part of his time to
the study of warfare he learns to
submerge his individuality in masked
drills and maneuvers which teach him the
fundamentals of the life he will soon
lead he is taught how to handle a rifle
under a drill master who is both able
and severe he is trained so that
handling a gun
becomes second nature to him in
preparation for the time when he will be
a full-fledged soldier ready to die for
his Emperor
anticipating worldwide expansion Japan
has four years maintained a school of
military government and colonial
administration where pick jeong japanese
learn the approved attitude and method
of ruling conquered people in a
conquered territory
the Emperor's future Gauleiters leader
Spartan existence become used to the
simple rations would be their luck until
the day of final victory at 17:00 every
Japanese becomes automatically eligible
for military service and on his
induction into the army his years of
military training and ingrained
discipline begin to serve the nation
averaging only 5 feet 3 in height and
117 pounds in weight the Japanese
soldier is expected to compensate for
his small size by his fanaticism in
battle under the eyes of an elite corps
of officers the new soldier spends
nearly 2 years learning how to take care
of himself
and it is a matter of pride with each
Japanese soldier that he conformed to
the accepted pattern
he is taught that the greater the odds
are against him the more glorious will
be his death building on this foundation
of the will to conquer the Japanese have
made good use of the offensive spirit
which inspires their people
today they believe themselves well on
the way to realizing their imperial
dream the dream of uniting all mankind
into one worldwide household with Japan
at its head this then is the enemy
primitive murderous and fanatical this
war machine this empire be beaten but
let us make no mistake for total victory
we must make total sacrifice against the
madness of Japan nothing less than all
our efforts will suffice
pink peace and security in our time
you